For the Ancient Egyptians, the cycle of life
itself began and ended with Isis and Osiris.
Their story is one of the oldest known myths, and
it informed spiritual beliefs, power structures,
and gender roles in Ancient Egypt and beyond. And
who wouldn’t be drawn to a tale that has it all?
And by all, I mean devious party tricks,
sibling rivalry, shape-shifting  quests,
true love – and a missing penis.
In 1922, the unsealing of King Tutankhamun’s
tomb opened a portal to Ancient Egypt.
Inthe burial chamber, carvings on the wall show
the young Pharaoh traveling to the afterlife.
Here he is welcomed by Isis, mother
of Pharaohs and goddess of protection,
and Osiris, king of the underworld.
Two of Egypt’s most powerful Gods,
Isis and Osiris appear throughout funerary
texts and art. King Tut’s iconic death mask
bears Osiris’ likeness, while symbols
of Iksis are etched across his coffin.
The influence of these two deities
extends far beyond mummies and tombs.
Long before Isis and Osiris,
there was the creator God Atum.
Some accounts identify him as the
creator of Shu, god of dry air,
and Tefnut, goddess of moisture, who were the
parents of Geb, the earth, and Nut, the sky.
Other versions say that Atum fashioned Geb
and Nut himself, separating earth from sky
when he discovered their illicit affair.
Either way, it’s a formidable family tree.
Geb and Nut had four children:
Isis, Osiris, Set, and Nephthys.
These deities paired off in the womb, with
Isis and Osiris falling for each other
and Set and Nephthys forming their own bond.
As first born, Osiris became ruler of the earth.
He was essentially the creator of society,
who brought law, farming, religion,
and education to the people. Not to be outdone,
Isis brought medicine, healing…and beer brewing.
If Osiris stood for order, Set stood for
chaos. Even with the restrained Nephthys
by his side, he couldn’t contain
his desire to destroy his brother.
Set was known for causing storms,
war, and general malaise.
But his most vicious plan began with a party.
At this gathering, Set produced an ornate
chest and proposed a game: whoever could fit
inside the chest, could keep it. All the Gods
tried to squeeze in, but none succeeded – for Set
had designed the chest for Osiris’ body alone.
As his brother settled in, Set slammed the
chest shut, sealed it, and flung it in the Nile.
As Set seized power over Egypt, the chest floated
down the Nile and washed up at the kingdom of Byblos. Here it merged with the trunkof a cedar tree,
which the King promptly cut down and used to prop up his palace - notknowing that Osiris’ body was inside.
The image of this pillar containing the
imprisoned God became the djed , a symbol
of stability in Egyptian architecture.
Back with the Gods, things were anything
but stable. Furious, Isis vowed to find her
husband and put an end to Set’s rule. She and
Nephthys took flight as falcons, questioning
everyone they could find for news of Osiris.
Eventually, a group of children
pointed them in the right direction.
Landing on the shores of Byblos, Isis transformed
into a human and set about charming the palace
maids--eventually gaining the favor of the queen.
Now an undercover nanny, Isis took to bathing the
infant prince in fire in order to instill some
godly strength – but when the king discovered her
actions he was so terrified that he promised
to give her anything in exchange for safety.
Of course, Isis demanded the chest.
She brought Osiris’ body back to the
banks of the Nile, hiding it in the reeds
until she could figure out how to revive him.
But Set found the body, hacking it into fourteen
pieces and scattering them across Egypt.
Once again, Isis set out in search of Osiris.
She soon tracked down thirteen parts of the
body, which she lovingly stitched back together.
But they had a little problem: Osiris’
penis had been eaten by a fish.
Isis had come too far to be thwarted by this. Some
say that she fashioned a new member for Osiris,
with others adding that she drew out his
last sexual powers with her beating wings.
Either way, the two used Osiris’ final moments on
earth to conceive an heir. By the power of Isis,
Osiris was briefly revived, given a proper burial,
and sent safely to the realm of the dead.
Here hewas resurrected as the king of the afterlife,
or Duat, where he would rule for eternity.
In the wake of Osiris’ departure, Isis raised
their son Horus in hiding. Under her guidance,
he grew into a strapping young God who defeated
Set to assume his rightful rule over Egypt.
The epic battle between Horus and Set was
sometimes used as a metaphor for the war between
Upper and Lower Egypt, with Horus’ triumph
standing for the unification of the region.
The story served as a guide to death for all
Ancient Egyptians. Isis’ retrieval of the chest
from Byblos informed the belief that Egyptians
should only be laid to rest on Egyptian soil,
and the second part of her quest highlights the
importance of protecting the body after death.
Isis painstakingly searched for
and reassembled Osiris’ body,
thus constructing what can be
considered the first mummy.
Her re-creation of the penis corresponds to
the belief that the body should be buriedintact.
During mummification, embalmers
would construct absent body parts for the dead.
This ensured that they would travel to
the underworld in the best possible shape.
For King Tut, this meant being buried
with his penis propped at a 90-degree angle,
a feature which scholars have
linked to Osiris’ postmortem fertility.
Embalmers often placed the
dead in decorated coffins,
which eventually became kanthropoid or
human-shaped to resemble Osiris’ chest.
Many bore the face of the God, and were
decorated with the wings of Isis and Nephthys.
The Pyramid texts of the Old Kingdom frame Osiris
as king and judge of the afterlife These writings
were a set of utterances and hymns, intended for
royalty to ensure safe passage to the afterlife.
To reach paradise, or the field of reeds, you
had to meet with Osiris in the Hall of Truth.
Here he weighed your heart against
the Feather of Truth,
which you’d hopefully kept nice and light by
steering clear of bad thoughts and actions.
If your heart wasn’t weighed
down, Osiris let you pass.
This encounter between god and mortals was
extended in the Coffin Texts of the Middle
Kingdom, which emphasize Osiris as the
judge of all people regardless of class.
In the New Kingdom, which occurred between
the sixteenth and eleventh century BCE,
the Book of the Dead became the
most popular guide to the afterlife.
A collection of funerary spells and
guidelines written over hundreds of years,
the Book guided the dead through face-offs
with demons, confessions to Gods,
the weighing of the heart, and other judgments
of the spirit. Isis and Osiris appear throughout
these texts, judging or guiding the
dead through their spiritual reckonings.
While Osiris reveals the challenges and promises
of the afterlife, Isis stands for life itself.
From food and water to the nourishing
powers of medicine and maternal instincts,
Isis presided over living things.
She was widely worshiped as the Protectress
and Mother of All Pharaohs, and is referred
to as “The Great One” in the Pyramid texts.
Her behavior following the death
of Osiris epitomizes the ingenuity
and perseverance that she was beloved for.
This triumph indicates her
possession of mighty magic,
which allows her to shapeshift, revive
the dead, and protect the vulnerable.
The awe-inspiring powers of Isis can be linked
to the elevated role of women in Ancient
Egypt. Women had autonomy over
marriage, property, and finances,
and could be Pharaohs in their own right.
Non-royal women also served as scribes, doctors,
and religious officials, carrying out different
forms of protection that Isis also embodied.
Over time, Isis became the supreme Egyptian God.
Her temples were erected across North Africa, as
well as Crete, Pompeii, and Northern Europe. The
Roman cult of Isis is still shrouded in mystery,
but we do know that her followers
launched a model ship filled with
offerings to the Goddess every year.
In the classical world, she was more
generally associated with the Goddess of
food and fertility Demeter, and her cult
in Rome came to rival that of Christianity.
It’s also been noted that Christian iconography
of the Madonna and child borrows from the
image of Isis protecting the infant Horus.
From mummification to mothering, she
informed a host of practices and ideals.
From temple paintings to burial
practices to secret rituals,
Osiris and Isis infused ancient
iconography and beliefs.
Our knowledge of their story myth comes
from a similarly diverse range of sources.
Found on the walls of ancient pyramids - and
aptly named the Pyramid Texts - the oldest
religious writings in the world reference the
grisly murder of Osiris. Later texts like the
Chester Beatty Papyrus and the Shabaka Stonealso allude to this event and its fallout,
while classical historians like Plutarch and DiodorusSiculus wrote their own versions of the myth.
While the premature death of Osiris and his
separation from Isis could be seen as a tragic
tale, the story reveals the Ancient Egyptian
belief that the boundaries between material
and spiritual, life and death, are porous.
For the Ancient Egyptians, Osiris offered
a poignant reminder that life
was fragile – even for a God.
As the great protector, Isis offered
guidance on that fragile path
and ensured that the channels between
the living and the lost were always open.